this video is sponsored by skillshare
being creative is pretty cool
take it from me i love making the videos
i do on youtube and if i'm being honest
i wouldn't have gotten anywhere if i
didn't take the steps to learn the craft
along the way
that's why i'm excited to talk about
skillshare the online learning community
with literally
thousands of classes that are each meant
to inspire
creators like the ones about making
effective instagram posts or editing
youtube videos or
if you're like me classes like
productivity for
creatives build a system that brings out
your best by thomas frank
because i can be a little disorganized
there are countless premium classes
being added all the time and because
it's curated specifically for learning
and nothing else
you'll never have to worry about sitting
through ads or any such nonsense
if you're interested in letting your
creativity blossom head on down to the
description and click on that special
link below
the first 1 000 of my subscribers to do
so will get a free trial of skillshare's
premium membership
and now on to the video
what's up guys bandit here you remember
when you were a kid and you tried to go
buy or rent a video game or a movie from
a store
but you couldn't because you weren't the
proper age requirement see
i can't relate because i was born in
1952 but you know who can relate to that
link from the legend of zelda kind of
you see
link is the reincarnation of the spirit
of the hero as many fans are very
familiar
with but even though this same spirit
reincarnates to battle evil time and
time again
for some reason he looks a bit different
every time and i'm not just talking
about hair color
link has been seen throughout the series
sometimes as a 9 year old sometimes as a
12 year old
a 16 year old or most recently as a 117
year old
this would be fine if it wasn't for one
key detail
from one key game that literally the
entire timeline is based off of
in ocarina of time there exists this
teeny tiny
massive little requirement for wielding
the legendary master sword
this is proven to us by the fact that
when he does draw the master sword it
puts him to sleep
automatically within the sacred realm
for seven years
until he awakens and raru explains that
he was specifically too
young to be the hero of time but is now
the proper
age this little detail of the age of the
hero is apparently
important enough that the entire
franchise's timeline was split over it
but yet in the wind waker link who was
designed to be around 12 years old and
i'll provide evidence for that in a bit
is garbed in the clothing of the hero
because he apparently reached the age of
the hero so
what is the age of the hero is it 12 is
it 16
i'm so glad you asked i just so happened
to make a video on that very subject
you're watching it right now so make
sure you like this video if you like
this video and subscribe for much more
content to come
and join me as we try to answer this
franchise-defining question
to begin let's determine how many links
there have been across the series
starting from the beginning point on the
timeline we have the link from skyward
sword the link from the minish cap the
link from four swords the link from
ocarina of time and majora's mask the
link from a link to the past and the
oracle games and
links awakening the link from a link
between worlds the link from zelda 1 and
2
the link from twilight princess the link
from four swords adventures
the link from the wind waker and phantom
hourglass the link from spirit tracks
and finally the link from breath of the
wild slash breath of the wild 2.
i mean there's also the potentially
three other links from triforce heroes
but i'll be honest with you i really
don't know what to do with this game it
does have an official timeline placement
and takes place in the lore of the
series but it's so
weird and doesn't have anything to do
with actual zelda lore
i mean come on they're fighting in a
kingdom where the worst thing that's
going to happen is the princess is going
to be forced to wear
unfashionable clothing forever and i
mean at least four swords and four
swords adventures features
one link that was split into four but
with triforce heroes there are also
apparently just
three literal links in general so i'm
sorry but for this list i'm just not
going to include the links
from triforce heroes anyway that leaves
us with 12 links over all the games
with some of them reprising their heroic
roles for sequels and the like
now let's attempt to figure out how old
each of these links are
and then try to identify a pattern
should one exist of course
starting again from the first game in
the timeline the hero of the skies is
17 and a half years old according to a
quote from kobayashi his
character designer the minish cap link's
age is completely unknown but due to his
design we can assume his age would be
similar to that of his look like the
hero of winds
who we'll get to in a second and
actually the same goes for the hero of
four swords as well
the famous hero of time from ocarina of
time has long been a debated age
as both a child and an adult with people
claiming for him to be
anywhere from 7 to 12 years old as a kid
and anywhere from 14 to 20 years old as
an adult
but in an interview with miyamoto from
iwata asks
miyamoto said this specifically about
the hero of time
when we decided to handle link growing
up from a 9 year old child to a more
mature 16 year old i wanted lots of
characters to fulfill
various roles the key takeaway here from
this quote is of course the fact that
directly from the mouth of the series's
creator himself
the hero of time as a child is 9 years
old and becomes 16 years old when tasked
with wielding the master sword
moving on the hero of winds as i
mentioned earlier was designed to be
around 12 years old according to a
direct quote from aonuma who may not
have created the entire series but has
for a long time been its producer and
director
in the official guide to the wind waker
called zelda box
he says quote this link is supposed to
be about
12 years old why they called this the
age of the hero in game is unknown but
aonuma sounded pretty direct if you ask
me
the proper age of the hero may have just
been lost to time in legend in game also
because the hero of winds from wind
waker and phantom hourglass looks
exactly like the other toon links from
the minish cap spirit tracks four swords
and four swords adventures
we can assume they're all at least
around the same age of 12 since we have
no information about the others ages
next up even though the hero of twilight
is said to be 17 years old in the
official game guide he's actually 16
years old according to a quote from an
interview how numa had with nintendo
dream in 2007
when aonuma was asked by the interviewer
by the way in this game link is 16 years
old
right he responded with quote being 16
years old is right before turning into
an adult the tv ad of the disc system
game adventure of links said
16 years so now link is 16 years old
which is another way of saying
yes moving right along the link from a
link to the past
the oracle games and links awakening is
around 16 years old as well
since this page scan from a nintendo
character reference guide from 1993
reveals that
zelda in a link to the past is 16 years
old at the time of the game
since link is historically the same age
as zelda it can be assumed that he is
also 16 at the time of the game the link
from a link between worlds doesn't have
a confirmed age but since that game is
supposed to be a parallel slash
spiritual successor to a link to the
past we can assume that link and zelda
are the same age as their predecessors
from a link to the past so
16 as well the link from the original
legend of zelda and its sequel
zelda 2 the adventure of link is 10 at
the time of the original game and 16 at
the time of its sequel as
proven by the adventure of link's
official game guide which states that
link's mark of the triforce began to
glow right around his 16th birthday
and zelda 2 takes place 6 years after
the original game according to hyrule
historia
so yeah 16 in the sequel minus 6 is 10
in the original
finally the link in breath of the wild
is 17 years old since he and zelda are
normally the same age and we know for a
fact that zelda's 17th birthday was the
same day that clementine destroyed
everything yeesh okay looking at the
data we've accumulated for link's age in
each game
there seems to actually be a pretty
simple solution to the puzzle and what's
better
is it can be explained within game lore
well
mostly you see the pattern here is that
all the links that appear as 16 or 17
year old boys
have one thing in common the master
sword the answer to the mystery of
link's age
could be that whenever the master sword
is needed to vanquish
evil an incarnation of the hero will
rise as a 16 year old boy
now you might be thinking but wait
doesn't the link from the original game
wield the sword at 10 years old well
that's actually the magic sword not the
master sword which of course operates
off of a different rule set
apparently the hero of the skies hero of
time hero of twilight hero of the past
hero of hyrule hero of winds and hero of
the wild are the links that wield the
master sword
and are all at least 16 years old with
two
explainable exceptions the hero of winds
was 12 when he drew the blade of evil's
bane but that's okay because one it
wasn't powered up at the time
two the spirit of the hero could have
actually been removed from that timeline
and three because that might not
actually be the original master sword
okay i realize that implies a whole lot
like enough to make
another entire theory about so i'll link
to the other entire theories i did about
the possible duplicate master sword on
the screen now and in the description
below
be sure to check it out if you're
interested after this video the second
exception is the hero of the wild or the
most recent iteration of link
even though he's playable as a 17 year
old i'm sorry a 117 year old who wields
the master sword
it's said in creating a champion that
quote since he was in possession of it
for a number of years prior to becoming
a champion
he was likely around 12 or 13 years old
when it happened
it being obtaining the master sword that
is but not to skirt over the issue
breath of the wild is the most
futuristic and most
unexplained zelda game to date since its
connections to previous zelda games
are both numerous and shrouded in
mystery for instance
if it's connected to the wind waker's
timeline that could be the second master
sword according to my theory so it could
possibly operate off of different rules
if it's connected to zelda 2 or to
twilight princess's timelines
then it would have to be the original
which would then not make much sense
the thing is since breath of the wild's
history is so shrouded in
unconfirmed mysteries i'm going to
disregard link's age when he picked up
the blade before the events of the game
and just go with the fact that
based on what we can see he is 17 when
he wields it in game so
back to the matter at hand exceptions
aside i think that when a hero is called
upon to wield the master sword
specifically
he will then appear as a 16 year old or
he will be
made to be a 16 year old like in ocarina
of time
in every other appearance of link
specifically the hero of minish kira of
light and hero from the original game
he's not required to take down ganon
therefore the master sword is not
necessary
meaning the spirit of the hero can rise
to the challenge at whatever age he
notices there is a challenge
again with the exception of the hero
from the original legend of zelda who
does defeat ganon with the use of the
magic sword and silver arrows instead
in summary it appears that throughout
the entire franchise
the spirit of the hero may appear
whenever evil is abound but the master
sword is the one that determines the
hero's age
this is of course just my theory though
what do you guys think
is link's age determined by the master
sword or is it a roll of the dice to see
what we get next let me know in the
comments below
hey guys thank you so much for watching
please consider leaving a like below if
you did enjoy the video so that it can
get spread around to other zelda fans
just like you and me with e3 right
around the corner we need to start
building that zelda hype and getting
zelda videos out to everyone and liking
this video is a great way to do just
that also double check and make sure
that you're subscribed to the channel if
you haven't already so that you are
front and center when new content drops
as always humongous thanks goes to my
bandit crew of which i have a few names
to announce
please say hello to amg november james p
dan gamble and retro spectre who have
all joined up with my elite
if you watching are interested in
getting your name up here and helping me
to
live and subsequently make videos like
this one click that join button below or
follow the links in the description to
my merch and patreon pages to join up
also down there are the links to my
social media pages so come follow me on
twitter and instagram for more
funny epic hilarious informative
generally awesome stuff that i do that's
all i've got for this one so as always i
hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day this is mass antenna bandit
signing out and looking forward to
seeing you in the next one peace
[Music]
you